um hi everybody
um welcome to stanford cs224 n also
known as ling 284
natural language processing with deep
learning i'm christopher manning and i'm
the main instructor for this class
so
what we hope to do today
is to dive right in so i'm going to
spend about 10 minutes talking about the
course
and then we're going to get straight
into content for reasons i'll explain in
a minute in a minute so we'll talk about
human language and word meaning i'll
then introduce the ideas of the word to
vec algorithm for learning word meaning
and then going from there we'll kind of
concretely work through how you can work
out objective function gradients with
respect to the word deveck algorithm
and say a teeny bit about how
optimization works and then right at the
end of the class i then want to spend a
little bit of time giving you a sense of
how these
word vectors work and what you can do
with them so really the key learning for
today is i want to give you a sense of
how amazing
deep learning word vectors are so we
have this really surprising result that
word meaning can be represented not
perfectly but really rather well by a
large vector of real numbers and you
know that's sort of in a way a common
place of the last decade of deep
learning but it flies in the face of
thousands of years of tradition and it's
really rather an unexpected result to
start focusing on
okay so um quickly what do we hope to
teach in this course so we've got three
primary goals um the first is to teach
you the foundations i a good deep
understanding of the effect of modern
methods for deep learning applied to nlp
so we are going to start with and go
through the basics and then go on to key
methods that are used in nlp recurrent
networks attention transformers and
things like that
we want to do something more than just
that we'd also like to give you some
sense of a big picture understanding of
human languages and what are the reasons
for why they're actually quite difficult
to understand and produce even though
humans seem to
do it easily now obviously if you really
want to learn a lot about this topic you
should enroll in and go and start doing
some classes in the linguistics
department but nevertheless for a lot of
you this is the only human language
content you'll see during your master's
degree or whatever and so we do hope to
spend a bit of time on that
starting today
and then finally we want to give you an
understanding of an ability
to build systems in pi torch for some of
the major problems in nlp so we'll look
at learning word meanings dependency
parsing machine translation question
answering
let's dive in to human language
once upon a time i had a lot longer
introduction that gave lots of examples
about human how human languages can be
misunderstood and complex i'll show a
few of those um
examples in later lectures
but since right for today
we're going to be focused on word
meaning i thought i'd just give um one
example which comes from a very nice
xkcd cartoon
and
um that isn't sort of about some of the
sort of syntactic ambiguities of
sentences but instead it's really
emphasizing the important point that
language is a social system constructed
and interpreted by people and that's
part of how and it changes as people
decide to
adapt its construction and that's part
of the reason why human languages are
great as an adaptive system for human
beings
but difficult as a system
or our computers to understand to this
day
so in this conversation um between the
two women one says anyway i could care
less and the other says i think you mean
you couldn't care less
saying you could care less implies you
care at least some amount
and the other one says i don't know
where these unbelievably complicated
brains drifting through a void trying in
vain to connect with one another by
blindly fleeing words out into the
darkness
every choice of phrasing spelling and
tone and timing carries countless
signals and contexts and subtexts and
more
and every listener interprets those
signals in their own way
language isn't a formal system language
is glorious chaos
you can never know for sure what any
words will mean to anyone
all you can do is try to get better at
guessing how your words affect people so
you can have a chance of finding the
ones that will make them feel something
like what you want them to feel
everything else is pointless
i assume you're giving me tips on how
you interpret words because you want me
to feel less alone
if so then thank you that means a lot
but if you're just running my sentences
past some mental checklist so you can
show off how well you know it
then i could care less
okay so that's ultimately um what our
goal is is to how to do a better job at
building um computational systems um
that
try to get better at guessing how their
words will affect other people and what
other people are meaning by the words
that they choose to say
so an interesting thing about human
language is it is a system that was
constructed by human beings
um
and it's a system that was constructed
you know relatively recently in some
sense so in discussions of artificial
intelligence um a lot of the time um
people
focus a lot on human brains and the
neurons buzzing by and this intelligence
um that's meant to be inside people's
heads but i just wanted to focus for a
moment on the role of language
there's actually
you know this is kind of controversial
but
you know it's not necessarily the case
that humans are much more intelligent
than some of the higher apes like
chimpanzees of bonobos right so
chimpanzees and bonobos have been shown
to be able to use pools to make plans
and in fact chimps have much better
short-term memory than human beings do
so relative to that if you look through
the history of life on earth human
beings develop language really recently
um how recently we kind of actually
don't know because you know there's no
fossils that say okay here's a language
speaker um but you know
most people estimate that language arose
for human beings sort of
you know
somewhere in the range of a hundred
thousand to a million years ago okay
that's a while ago but compared to the
process of evolution of life on earth
that's kind of um blinking an eyelid
um but that powerfulness communication
between human beings quickly set off our
ascendancy over other creatures
um so it's kind of interesting that the
ultimate power turned out not to be have
been poisonous fangs or being super fast
or super big but having the ability to
communicate
with other members of your tribe
it was much more recently again that
humans developed writing which allowed
knowledge to be communicated across
distances of time and space
and so that's only about
5 000 years old the power of writing so
in just a few thousand years
the ability to preserve and share
knowledge took us from the bronze age to
the smartphones and tablets of today
so a key question for artificial
intelligence and human computer
interaction is how to get computers to
be able to understand the information
conveyed in human languages
simultaneously artificial intelligence
requires computers with the knowledge of
people
fortunately now our ai systems might be
able to benefit from a virtuous cycle we
need knowledge to understand language
and people well but it's also the case
that a lot of that knowledge is
contained in language spread out across
the books and web pages of the world and
that's one of the things we're going to
look at in this course is how that we
can sort of build on that virtuous cycle
a lot of progress has already been made
and i just want to very quickly um give
a sense of that
so
in the last
decade or so and especially in the last
few years with newer methods of machine
translation we're now in a space where
machine translation really works
moderately well so again from the
history of the world this is just
amazing right for thousands of years
learning other people's languages was a
human task which required a lot of
effort and concentration but now we're
in a world where you could just hop on
your web browser and think oh i wonder
what the news is in kenya today and you
can head off over to a kenyan website
and you can see something like this and
you can go huh and you can then ask
google um to translate it for you um
from swahili and you know the
translation isn't quite perfect but it's
you know it's reasonably good so the
newspaper tuko has been informed that
local government minister lingsan
and his transport counterparts city me
died within two separate hours so you
know within two separate hours is kind
of awkward but essentially we're doing
pretty well at getting the information
out of this page and so um that's quite
amazing
um the single biggest
development in nlp
for the last year certainly in the
popular media media
was
gpt
um which was a huge new model that was
released by open ai um
what gpt 3 is about and why it's great
is actually a bit subtle and so i can't
really go through all the details of
this here but it's exciting because it
seems like it's the first step on the
path to what we might call universal
models where you can train up one
extremely large model on something like
that library picture i showed before
and it just has
knowledge of the world knowledge of
human languages knowledge of how to do
tasks and then you can apply it to do
all sorts of things so no longer are we
building a model to detect spam and then
a model to detect pornography and then a
model to detect um
whatever foreign language content and
just building all these separate
supervised classifiers for every
different task we've now just built up a
model that understands so exactly what
it does is it just predicts
following words so
on the left it's
being told to write um about elon musk
in the style of
dr seuss
and it started off with some text and
then it's generating more text and the
way it generates more text
is literally
by just predicting one word at a time
following words
come to complete its text
but this has a very powerful facility
because what you can do with
3 is you can give it a couple of
examples of what you'd like it to do so
i can give it some text and say i broke
the window
change it into a question what did i
break i gracefully saved the day i
changed it into a question what did i
gracefully save so this prompt um tells
gpt 3 what
i'm wanting it to do and so then if i
give it another statement like i gave
john flowers i can then say gpt-3
predict what words come next and it'll
follow my prompt and produce who did i
give flowers to or i can say i gave her
a rose and a guitar and it will follow
the idea of the pattern and do who did i
give a rose and a guitar to
and actually this one model can then do
an amazing range of things including
many there's quite surprising to do at
all to give just one example of that
another thing that you can do
is get it to
translate human language sentences into
sql so this can make it much easier to
do cs145
so having given it a couple of examples
of sql translation of human language
text which i'm this time not showing
because it won't fit on my slide i can
then give it a sentence like how many
users have signed up since the start of
and it turns it into sql or i can give
it another query what is the average
number of influences each user subscribe
to and again it then converts that into
sql
so gpt gpt-3 knows a lot about the
meaning of language and the meaning of
other things like sql and can fluently
manipulate it
okay so that leads us straight into this
top meaning and how do we represent the
meaning of a word well what is meaning
well we could look up something like the
webster dictionary and say okay
the idea is represented by a word the
idea that a person wants to express by
using words signs etc
um
those webster's dictionary definitions
really focused on the word idea somehow
but this is pretty close to the
commonest way that linguists think about
meaning
so that they think of word meaning as
being appearing between a a word which
is a signifier or symbol and the thing
that it signifies the signified thing
which is an idea or thing so that the
meaning of the word chair
is the set of things that are chairs
and that's referred to as denotational
semantics
a term that's also used and similarly
applied for the semantics of programming
languages
this model isn't very deeply
implementable like
how do i go from the idea that okay
chair means the set of chairs in the
world just something i can manipulate
meaning within my computers so
traditionally the way that meaning has
normally
been handled in natural language
processing systems is to make use of
resources like dictionaries and thesauri
in particular a popular one is wordnet
which organized words and terms into
both synonym sets
words that can mean the same thing and
hypernyms which correspond to is a
relationships um and so for the is a
relationships you know we can kind of
look at the hyponyms of panda and
panda is a kind of proceed whatever
those are like i guess that's probably
with red pandas um which is a kind of
carnivore
which is a kind of placenta which is
kind of mammal and you sort of head up
this um hyponym um
hierarchy so wordnet has been a greater
resource for nlp but it's also been
highly deficient so
it lacks a lot of nuance
so for example in word net proficient is
listed as a synonym for good but you
know maybe that's sometimes true but it
seems like in a lot of context it's not
true and you mean something rather
different when you say proficient versus
good um it's limited as a human
constructed um thesaurus so in
particular there's lots of words and
lots of uses of words that just aren't
there including you know anything um
that is you know
sort of more current terminology like um
wicked is there for the wicked witch but
not for more modern colloquial uses um
ninja certainly isn't there for the kind
of description some people make of
programmers and it's
kind of impossible to keep up to date um
so it requires a lot of human labor but
even when you have that
you know it has a sets of synonyms but
doesn't really have a good sense of
words that means something similar so
um fantastic and great means something
similar without really being
synonyms and so this idea of meaning
similarity is something that would be
really useful to make progress on and
where deep learning models
excel okay so what's the problem with a
lot of traditional nlp well the problem
with a lot of traditional nlp
is that words are regarded as discrete
symbols so we have symbols like hotel
conference motel our words
which in deep learning speak we refer to
as a localist representation
and that's because
if you
in
statistical or machine learning systems
want to represent these symbols that
each of them is a separate thing so the
standard way of representing them and
this is what you do
in something like a statistical model if
you're building a logistic regression
model with words as features is that you
represent them as one hot vectors so you
have a dimension for each different word
so maybe like in my example here are my
representations as vectors for motel and
hotel
um
and so that means that we have to have
huge vectors corresponding to the number
of words in our vocabulary so the kind
of if you had a
high school english dictionary it
probably had about 250 000 words in it
um but there are many many more words in
the language really so maybe we at least
want to have a 500 000 um dimensional
vector to be able to cope with that
okay um but the bigger even bigger
problem with the discrete symbols is
that we don't have this notion of word
relationships and similarity so for
example in web search if a user searches
for seattle motel we'd also like to
match on documents containing seattle
hotel
but our problem is we've got these
one-hot vectors for the different words
and so in a formal mathematical sense
these two vectors are orthogonal that
there's no natural notion of similarity
between them whatsoever
well there are some things that we could
do but try and do about that and people
did do about that um in
you know before 2010 we could say hey we
could use word net synonyms and we count
things that list the synonyms is similar
anyway or hey maybe we could somehow
build up
representations of words that have
meaning overlap and people did all of
those things but they tended to fail
badly from incompleteness so instead
what i want to introduce today is the
modern
deep learning method of doing that where
we encode similarity in a real value
vector themselves so how do we go about
doing that
okay and the way we do that is by
exploiting this idea called
distributional semantics
so the idea of distributional semantics
is
again something that when you first see
it
maybe feels a little bit crazy
because rather than having something
like denotational semantics what we're
now going to do is say that a word's
meaning is going to be given by the
words that frequently appear close to it
jr firth was a british linguist
from the middle of last century and one
of his pithy slogans that everyone
quotes at this moment is you shall know
a word by the company it keeps
and so this idea that you can
represent
a sense for words meaning as a notion of
what context it appears in has been a
very successful idea one of the most
successful ideas that's used throughout
statistical and deep learning nlp
it's actually an interesting idea um
more philosophically
so
that there are kind of interesting
connections for example in
wittgenstein's later writings he became
enamored of a use theory of meaning and
this is a sin in some sense a use theory
of meaning but whether you know it's the
ultimate theory of semantics it's
actually still pretty controversial but
it proves to be an extremely
computational sense of semantics which
has just led to it being used everywhere
very successfully um in deep learning
systems
so when a word appears in a text
it has a context which are the set of
words that appear
and so for a particular word my example
here is banking
we'll find a bunch of places where
banking occurs
in texts and we'll collect the sort of
nearby words as context words and we'll
see
say that those words that are appearing
that kind of muddy brown color around
banking that those context words will in
some sense represent the meaning of the
word banking
um while i'm here let me just mention
one distinction that will come up
regularly
when we're talking about a word um in
our natural language processing class
we sort of have two senses of word
which are referred to as types and
tokens so there's a particular instance
for word so there's in the first example
government debt problems turning turning
into banking crises there's banking
there and that's a token of the word
banking but then i've collected a bunch
of instances of quote unquote the word
banking and when i say the word banking
and a bunch of examples of it i'm then
treating banking as a type which refers
to you know the uses and meaning the
word banking has across instances
okay so
um what are we going to do
with these
distributional
models of language well what we want to
do
is we're going based on looking at the
words that occur in context as vectors
that we want to build up
a dense
real valued vector
for each word that in some sense
represents the meaning of that word and
the way it all represent the meaning of
that word is
that this vector will be useful
for predicting other words that occur in
the context
of this
um so in this example to keep it
manageable on the slide
vectors are only eight dimensional um
but
in reality we use considerably bigger
vectors so a very common size is
actually 300 dimensional vectors
okay so for each word that's a word type
we're going to have a word vector
these are also used with other
names
they're referred to as newer word
representations
or for a reason they'll become clearer
on the next slide they're referred to as
word embeddings so these are now a
distributed representation not a
localist representation because the
meaning of the word banking is spread
over all 300 dimensions of the vector
okay these are called word embeddings
because effectively when we have a whole
bunch of words
these representations place them all in
a high dimensional vector space
and so they're embedded into that space
now unfortunately human beings are very
bad at looking at 300
dimensional vector spaces or even eight
dimensional vector spaces so the only
thing that i can really display to you
here is a two-dimensional projection of
that space now even that's useful um but
it's also important to realize that when
you're making a two-dimensional
projection of a 300 dimensional space
you're losing almost in all the
information in that space and a lot of
things will be crushed together that
don't actually deserve to be better um
so here's um my
word embeddings of course you can't see
any of those at all
but if i zoom in and then i zoom in
further what you'll already see is that
the representations we've learned
distributionally do a
just a good job at grouping together
similar um
words so in this sort of overall picture
i can zoom into one part of the space is
actually the part that's up here in this
view of it um and it's got words for
countries so not only are countries
generally grouped together um even the
sort of particular subgroupings of
countries
make a certain amount of sense and down
here we then have nationality words if
we go to another part of the space we
can see different kind of words so here
are
verbs and we have ones like come and go
are very similar um
saying and thinking words say think
expect a kind of similar and by
nearby
over in the bottom right we have sort of
verbal auxiliaries and copulas so have
had hairs um forms of the verb to be
and certain contentful verbs are similar
to copula verbs because they describe
states you know he remained angry he
became angry and so they're actually
then grouped close together to the word
the verb to be so there's a lot of
interesting structure um
in this space um that then represents
the meaning of words so the algorithm
i'm going to
introduce now is one that's called word
to vec which was um introduced by tamash
mikulov and colleagues in 2013
as a framework for learning word vectors
and it's sort of a simple and easy to
understand place to start
so the idea
is we have a
a lot of text from somewhere which we
commonly refer to as a corpus of text
corpus is just the latin word for body
so it's a body of text
and so then we choose a fixed vocabulary
which will typically be large but
nevertheless truncated so we get rid of
some of the really rare words so we
might say vocabulary size of four
hundred thousand and we then
create for ourselves a vector for each
word
okay so then what we do is we want to
work out what's a good vector um to for
each word and the really interesting
thing is that we can learn these word
vectors from just a big pile of text by
doing this distributional similarity
task of being able to predict well what
words occur in the context of other
words so in particular we're going to
iterate through words in the text and so
at any moment we have a center word um
c
and context words outside of it which
we'll call o
and then
based on the current word vectors we're
going to calculate the probability of a
context word
occurring
given the center word according to our
current model
but then we know that certain words did
actually occur in the context of that
center word and so what we want to do is
then keep adjusting the word vectors to
maximize the probability that's assigned
to words that actually occur in the
context of the center word as we proceed
through these texts
so to start to make that a bit more
concrete this is what we're doing um
so we have a piece of text we choose our
center word which is here into and then
we say well
if a model of predicting the probability
of context words given the center word
and this model will come to in a minute
but it's defined in terms of our word
vectors
so let's see what probability it gives
to the words that actually occurred in
the to the context of this word
it gives them some probability but maybe
be nice if the probability of the sign
was higher so then how can we change our
word vectors to raise those
probabilities and so we'll do some
calculations with into being the center
word and then we'll just go on to the
next word and then we'll do the same
kind of calculations and keep on
chunking
so the big question then is well what
are we doing for working out the
probability of a word occurring in the
context of the center word
and so that's the central part of what
we develop as the word
object
so this is the overall model that we
want to use so
for each position in our corpus our body
of text
we want to predict context words within
a window of fixed size m
given the center word wj
and we want to become good at doing that
so we want to give high probability to
words that occur in the context
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to work out what's formally the
data likelihood as to how good a job we
do at predicting words in the context of
other words
and so formally that likelihood is going
to be defined in terms of our word
vectors so they're the parameters of our
model and it's going to be calculated as
taking the product of
using each word as the center word and
then the product of each word and a
window around that of the probability of
predicting that context word
in the center word
and so to learn this model we're going
to have an objective function sometimes
also called a cost or a loss that we
want to optimize and essentially what we
want to do is we want to maximize the
likelihood of the context we see around
center words
but following standard practice we
slightly fiddle that
because rather than dealing with
products it's easier to deal with sums
and so we work with log likelihood and
once we take log likelihood all of our
products
turn into sums we also work with the
average log likelihood so we've got a
one on t term here for the number of
words in the corpus and finally for no
particular reason
we like to minimize our objective
function rather than maximizing it so we
stick a minus sign in there and so then
by minimizing this objective function j
of theta that comes
maximizing our predictive accuracy
okay
so that's the setup but we still haven't
made any progress in how do we calculate
the probability of a word occurring in
the context given the center word and so
the way we're actually going to do that
is we have vector representations
for each word and we're going to work
out the probability
simply in terms of the word vectors now
at this point there's a little technical
point we're actually going to give to
each word two word vectors
one word vector for when it's used as
the center word and a different
word vector when it's used as a context
word um this is done because it just
simplifies the math and the optimization
so it seems a little bit ugly but
actually
makes building word vectors a lot easier
and
really we can come back to that and
discuss it um later but that's what it
is and so then once we have these word
vectors um the
equation that we're going to use for
giving the probability of
a context word appearing given the
center word is that we're going to
calculate it using the expression in the
middle bottom of my slide
so
let's sort of
pull that apart just a little
bit more
um
so
what we have here with this expression
is so for a particular center word and a
particular
context word o we're going to look up
the vector representation of each word
so they're u of o and v of c
and so then we're simply going to take
the dot product of those two vectors so
dot product is a natural measure for
similarity between words because in any
particular
dimension
uh
positive you'll get some a component
that adds to the dot products um if both
are negative it'll add a lot to the dot
product some if one's positive and one's
negative um it'll subtract from this
similarity measure um if both of them
are zero it won't change the similarity
so it sort of seems a sort of plausible
idea to just take a dot product and
thinking well if two words have a larger
dot product that means they're more
similar
and so then after that
we're sort of really doing nothing more
than okay we want to use dot products to
represent word similarity and now let's
do the dumbest thing that we know how
to turn this into a probability
distribution
well what do we do well firstly
well taking a dot product of two vectors
that might come out as positive or
negative but well if we want to have
probabilities we can't have negative
probabilities so a simple way to avoid
negative probabilities is to
exponentiate them because then we know
everything is positive and so then we're
always getting a positive number in the
numerator
but for probabilities we also want to
have the numbers add up to one so we
have a probability distribution so we're
just normalizing in the obvious way
where we divide through by the sum of
the numerator quantity for each
different word and the vocabulary and so
then necessarily that gives us a
probability distribution
so all the rest of that that i was just
talking through
what we're using there is what's called
the softmax function so the softmax
function will take any
rn vector and turn it into things
between um zero to one um
and so we can take numbers and put them
through this soft max and turn them into
probability distribution right so the
name comes from the fact that it's sort
of like a max um so because of the fact
that we exponentiate that really
emphasizes the big contents in the
different dimensions of calculating
similarities so most of the probability
goes to the most similar things um and
it's called soft because well it doesn't
do that absolutely it'll still
give some probability to everything
that's in the slightest bit similar i
mean on the other hand it's a slightly
weird name because you know max normally
takes a set of things and just returns
one the biggest of them whereas the
softmax is taking a set of numbers and
is scaling them but is returning the
whole probability distribution
okay so now we have all the pieces of
our model and so how do we
make our word vectors
well the idea of what we want to do
is we want to
fiddle our word vectors in such a way
that we minimize our loss i that we
maximize the probability of the words
that we actually saw in the context of
the center word and so
theta the theta represents all of our
model parameters in one very long vector
so for our model here the only
parameters are our word vectors so we
have for each word
two vectors it's context vector and its
center vector and each of those is a d
dimensional vector where d might be 300
and we have v many words
so we end up with this big huge vector
which is 2 v
long which
if you have a 500 000 vocab times the
300 dimensional
the time um small method i can do in my
head but it's got millions and millions
of parameters so i've got millions and
millions of parameters
and we somehow want to fiddle them all
to maximize
the prediction of context words
and so the way we're going to do that
then is
we use calculus so what we want to do is
take that math that we've seen
previously and say huh well with this
objective function um we can work out
derivatives and so we can work out
where the gradient is so how we can walk
downhill to minimize loss so we're at
some point and we can figure out what
what is downhill and we can then
progressively walk downhill and improve
our model and so what our job is going
to be is to compute all of those vector
gradients
okay um
so at this point i then want to kind of
um show a little bit more as to how we
can actually um do that
and
a couple more slides here but
maybe i'll just try and
things again and move to my
interactive whiteboard what we wanted to
do
right so
we had our overall
we had our overall j theta that we
were wanting to minimize our average
neglog likelihood so that was the minus
one on t
of the sum
of t equals one to big t which was our
text length and then we were going
through the words in each context so
we're doing
j
between m words on each side um except
itself um and then what we wanted to do
was in the side there we were then we
were working out the log
probability of the context word
at that position
um given the word that's in the center
position t
and so then we converted that
into
um
our word vectors by saying that the
probability
of
o given c
is going to be expressed as
the
um this soft max of the dot product
okay and so now what we want to do
is
work out
the gradient the direction of downhill
for
this
last gen and so the way we're doing that
is we're working out the partial
derivative
of
this expression with respect
to every parameter in the model and all
the parameters in the model are the
components the dimensions of the word
vectors of every word and so we have
um the center word vectors and the
outside word vectors
so here um i'm just going to do
the
center word vectors
but on homework on a future homework
assignment 2
the outside word vectors will show up
and they're kind of similar so what
we're doing is we're working out the
partial derivative
with respect to our center word vector
which is you know maybe a 300
dimensional word vector
of
this probability of o give c um and
since we're using log probabilities of
the log of this probability of o given c
of this x of
u of o t v c
over
my writing will get worse and worse
sorry um i've already made a mistake
haven't i the sum
um the sum of w equals one to the
vocabulary of the expert
uwt
vc
okay um
well at this point things start off
pretty easy so what we have here is
something that's log of a over b so
that's easy we can turn this into log a
minus log b
but before i go further i'll just make a
comment at this point um
you know so at this point um my audience
divides on into
right there are some people in the
audience um for which maybe a lot of
people
[Music]
ah this is um really elementary math
i've seen this a million times before
and he isn't even explaining it very
well um
and if you're in that group well feel
free to look at your email or on the
newspaper or whatever else is best
suited to you but i think there are also
um other people in the class who oh the
last time i saw calculus was when i was
in high school
for which that's not the case and so i
wanted to spend a few minutes um going
through this a bit concretely
so that to try and get over the idea
that you know even
though
most of deep learning and even word
vector learning seems like magic that
it's not really magic um it's really
just doing math and one of the things we
hope is that you do actually understand
this math that's being done
so i'll keep along and do a bit more of
it okay so then what we have
is sort of use this way of writing
the log
and so then we can say that that
expression above equals the partial
derivatives with
of vc
of
the
log of the numerator
log x u o t v c
minus
um
the partial derivative
of the log of
of the
denominator so that's then the sum
of w equals 1 to v
of the x
of u
w t
v
c
okay so at that point i have
um
my numerator here and my former
denominator there
um so at that point
there are starts the first part is the
numerator part so the numerator part is
really really easy
so
um we have here
that log and x but just inverses of each
other so they just go away so that
becomes
the
derivative
with respect to
vc
of
just what's left behind which is you
u0 dot product and with vc
okay um and so the thing to be aware of
is you know we're still doing this
multivariate calculus so what we have
here is calculus with respect to a
vector like hopefully you saw some of in
math 51 or some other place not um high
school um single variable calculus on
the other hand um you know to the extent
you and half remember some of this stuff
most of the time you can just do fi
perfectly well by thinking about what
happens um with one
dimension at a time and it generalizes
the multivariable calculus so if about
um all that you remember of calculus is
that d dx of a x equals a
really
it's the same thing that we're going to
be using here that here we have
the
the outside word
dot producted
with the vc well at the end of the day
that's going to have terms of sort of u0
component 1 times
the center word component 1 plus
u um zero component two
plus
um
this were component two and so we're
sort of using this bit over here and so
what we're going to be getting out is
the u0 and
u01 and the u0 2
so this will be all that is left with
respect to vc1 when we take its
derivative with respect to vc1 and this
term will be the only thing left when we
take the derivative with respect to the
variable um vc2
so the end result of
taking the vector derivative of u0
dot product and with vc is simply going
to be u0
okay great
so that's progress
so then at that point
we go on and we say oh damn we still
have
the
the denominator
and that um slightly more complex but
not so bad so then we want to take the
partial derivatives with respect to vc
of the log of the denominator
okay and so then at this point um the
one tool that we need to know and
remember is how to use the chain rule so
the chain rule is when you're wanting to
work out um
of having derivatives of compositions of
functions so we have f of g
of
whatever x but here it's going to be vc
and so we want to say okay what we have
here is we're working out a composition
of functions so here's our f
um and here is
our
x
which is
g of v c
actually maybe i shouldn't call it x
um
oops
maybe i was
it's probably better to call it z or
something um
okay so when we then
want to
work out um
the chain rule well what do we do
we take the derivative of f
at the point z
and so at that point we have to actually
remember something we have to remember
that the derivative of log is the one on
x function so this is going to be equal
to
the
1 on x
for
z so that's then going to be 1 over the
sum of w equals 1 to v
of x
of
u
t
v c
multiplied by
the derivative
of
the inner function so
so the derivative
of
um
the part
that is remaining
i hope i'm getting this right the sum
of
oh and there's one trick here at this
point we do want to have a change of
index so we want to say the sum of x
equals 1 to v
of x
of u of x
v c
since we can
get into trouble if we don't
change that variable um to be using a
different one
okay so at that point we're making some
progress
but we still want to work out the
derivative of this and so what we want
to do is apply the chain rule once more
so now
here's our f and in here is our new z
equals g of vc
and so
we then sort of repeat over so we can
move the um derivative
inside uh some always
so we're then taking the derivative
of this
and so
then
the derivative of x
is itself
okay so we're going to just have x of u
x t v c
times
um
there's the sum of x equals 1 to v
times
the derivative
um of u x
t v c
okay and so then this is what we've
worked out before
we can just rewrite as ux
okay
so we're now making progress
um
so
if we start putting all of that together
what we have is
um the derivative
or the partial derivatives with vc of
this log probability
right we have the numerator which was
just u0
um minus
um we then had the sum of
the numerator sum over x equals
1 to v
of x
u x t
dc times u of x
then
that was multiplied by our first term
that came from the one on x which gives
you the sum of w equals one to v
of the x
of u w
t v c
and this is the fact that we change the
variables um became important and so by
just sort of rewriting that a little um
we can get that that equals u0
minus
um the sum
of v equals oh sorry x
all right x equals
1 to
v
of
this x view of x t v c
over
the sum
of w equals 1 to v
of x u w t v c
times u of x
and so at that point this sort of
interesting thing has happened that um
we've ended up getting straight back
exactly the soft max formula probability
that we saw
when we started um
we can just rewrite that more
conveniently as saying this equals u0
minus the sum over x equals 1 to v
of the probability of x given c
times ux
and so what we have at that moment is
this thing here is an expectation
and so this is an an average over all
the context vectors weighted by their
probability according to the model and
so it's always the case
with these softmax style models that
what you get out for the derivatives is
you get obs the observed
um
minus the expected so our model is good
if our model on average predicts exactly
um the word vector that we actually see
and so we're going to try and adjust the
parameters of our model
so
it does that much of all
um now i mean
we try and make it do it as much as
possible i mean of course as you'll find
you can never get close right you know
if i just say to you okay
the word is croissant which words are
going to um occur in the context of
croissant i mean you can't answer that
there are all sorts of sentences that
you could say that involve the word
croissant so actually our particular
probability estimates are going to be
kind of small but
nevertheless we want to sort of fiddle
our word vectors to try and make those
estimates as high as we possibly can
so
i've gone on about this stuff
um
a bit but haven't actually
sort of shown you any of what actually
happened sorry i just want to quickly um
show you
a bit of that
as to what actually happens with word
vectors um so here's a simple little
ipython notebook
which is also what you'll be using for
assignment one only um so in the first
cell i import a bunch of stuff
um so we've got numpy for our vectors
matplotlib
plotting off it learns kind of your
machine learning um swiss army knife
gensim is a package that you may well
not have seen before it's a package
that's often used for word vectors it's
not really
used for deep learning so this is the
only time you'll see it in the class but
if you just want a good package for
working with word vectors and some other
application it's a
good one to know about
okay so then in my second cell here
i'm loading
a particular set of word vectors so
these are our glove word vectors that we
made at stanford in 2014
and i'm loading a hundred dimensional
word vectors um so that things are a
little bit quicker for me um while i'm
doing things here sort of do this
model of bread and croissant um well
what i've just got here is um word
vectors so i just wanted to sort of um
show you that there are um word vectors
hmm
well
maybe i should have loaded those word
vectors in advance hmm
let's see
oh okay well i'm in business um
okay so right so here are my word
vectors for um bread and croissant
and while and seeing that maybe these
two words are a bit similar so both of
them are negative in the first dimension
positive and the second negative in the
third
positive and the fourth negative and the
fifth so it sort of looks like they
might have a fair bit of dot product
which is kind of what we want because
bread and croissant are kind of similar
um but what we can do is actually ask
the model and these are gen sim
functions now you know what are the most
similar words so i can ask for croissant
um what
are the most similar words to that and
it will tell me it's things like brioche
baguette focaccia so that's pretty good
pudding is perhaps a little bit more
questionable
we can say
most similar to the usa and it says
canada america usa with periods united
states that's pretty good
most similar to banana
um i get out coconuts mangoes bananas
sort of fairly tropical
very great um
now before finishing though i want to
show you something slightly more than
just similarity which is one of the
amazing things that people observed with
these word vectors and that was to say
you can actually sort of do arithmetic
in this vector space that makes sense
and so in particular people suggested
this analogy task and so the idea of the
analogy task is you should be able to
start with a word like king and you
should be able to subtract out a male
component from it add back in a woman
component and then you should be able to
ask well what word is over here and what
you'd like is that the word over there
is queen
um
and so
this sort of little bit of so we're
going to do that um
with this sort of same most similar
function which is actually more so as
well as having positive words you can
ask for most similar negative words and
you might wonder what's most negatively
similar to a banana and you might be
thinking oh it's um i don't know
um some kind of meat or something
actually that by itself isn't very
useful because when you could just ask
for
most negatively similar things you tend
to get
crazy strings that were found in the
data set
that you don't know what they mean if
anything
but if we put the two together we can
use the most similar function with
positives and negatives to do analogies
so we're going to say we want a positive
king we want to subtract out negatively
man we want to then add in positively
woman and find out what's most similar
to this point in the space so my analogy
function does that
precisely that by taking
a couple of most similar ones and then
subtracting out um
the negative one and so we can try out
this analogy function so i can do the
analogy i show in the picture
with
man as to king as woman is
fight
sorry i'm not saying this right um yeah
man is the king as woman is too oh
sorry i haven't done my cells
um
okay man is the king as a woman as the
queen so um that's great and that's um
works well
i mean and you can do it the sort of
other way around king is to man as queen
as to woman um if this only worked for
that one freakish example um you maybe
um wouldn't be very impressed but you
know it actually turns out like it's not
perfect but you can do all sorts of fun
analogies with this and they actually
work so you know i could ask for
something like
an analogy
um
oh here's a good one
australia
is to be uh
as
france is to what
and you can think about what you think
the answer that one should be
and it comes out as
champagne which is pretty good or i
could ask for something like analogy
pencil
is to
sketching
as camera
is to
what
um and it says photographing
um you can also do the analogies with
people um at this point i have to point
out that this data was um and the model
was built in 2014
so you can't ask anything about um
donald trump in it well you can trump is
in there but not as president but i
could ask something like analogy
obama is to
clinton as reagan
is
to what and you can
think of what you think is the right
analogy there
the analogy it returns is nixon
so i guess that depends on what you
think of bill clinton as to whether you
think that was a good analogy or not you
can also
do sort of linguistic analogies with it
so you can do something like analogy
tall
is to tallest
as
long
is to what and it does longest so it
really just sort of
knows a lot about the meaning behavior
of words and you know i think when these
um
methods were first developed and
hopefully still for you that you know
people were just gobsmacked about how
well this actually worked at capturing
of words and so these word vectors then
went everywhere as a new representation
that was so powerful for working out
word meaning and so that's our starting
point for this class and we'll say a bit
more about them next time and they're
also the basis of what you're looking at
for the first assignment can i ask a
quick question about the distinction
between the two vectors per word
yes
um my understanding is that there can be
several context words per
uh word in the vocabulary like word in
the vocabulary um but then if there's
only two vectors i kind of i thought the
distinction between the two is that one
it's like the actual word and one's like
the context word but the multiple
context words like how do you how do you
pick just two then well so we're doing
every one of them right so
like
um maybe i won't turn back on the screen
share but you know we were doing
in the objective function there was a
sum
over
you so you've got you know this big
corpus of text right so you're taking a
sum over every word which is it
appearing as the center word and then
inside that there's a second sum
which is
for each word in the context so you are
going to count each word as a context
word and so then for one particular term
of that objective function you've got a
particular context word and a particular
um center word but you're then sort of
summing over different context words for
each center of the word and then you're
summing over all of the the decisions of
different center words and and to say um
a little just a sentence more about
having two vectors i mean you know in
some sense it's an ugly detail but it's
was done to make things sort of simple
and fast so you know if you
look at
the math carefully if you sort of
treated
this two vectors as the same so if you
use the same vectors for center and
context
and you say okay let's work out the
derivatives
things get uglier and the reason that
they get uglier is
it's okay when i'm iterating over all
the choices of um context word oh my god
sometimes the context word is going to
be the same as the center word and so
that messes with working out um my
derivatives
whereas by taking them as separate
vectors that never happens so it's easy
um but the kind of interesting thing is
you know saying that you have these two
different representations
sort of just ends up really sort of
doing no harm and my wave my hands
argument for that is you know since
we're kind of moving through each
position the corpus one by one you know
something a word that is the center word
at one moment is going to be a context
word at the next moment and the word
that was the context word is going to
have become the center word so you're
sort of doing the um
the computation both ways in each case
and so you should be able to convince
yourself that the two representations
for the word end up being very similar
and they do not not identical for
technical reasons at the ends of
documents and things like that but very
very similar
and so effectively you tend to get two
very similar representations for each
word and we just average them and call
that the word vector and so when we use
word vectors we just have one vector for
each word
that makes sense thank you
i have a question purely of curiosity so
we started when we projected the
vectors the word vectors onto the 2d
surface we saw like little clusters of
words that are similar to each other and
then later on we saw that um with the
analogies thing we kind of see that
there's these directional vectors that
sort of indicate like the ruler of or
the ceo of something like that and so
i'm wondering is there are there
relationships between those relational
vectors themselves such as like is the
um the ruler of vector sort of similar
to the ceo of vector which is very
different from like is makes a good
sandwich with vector
is there any research on that
that's a good question um
how will you stump me already in the
first lecture ah
i mean that
yeah i can't actually think of a piece
of research and so i'm not sure i have a
confident and i'm not sure i have a
confident answer i mean it seems like
that's a really easy thing to check um
with how much you have one of these sets
of um word vectors that it seems um like
and for any relationship that
is represented well enough by word you
should be able to see if it comes out
kind of similar
um
huh
i mean i'm not sure we can we can look
and see
yeah that's totally okay just just
curious
i'm sorry i missed the last little bit
to your answer to first question so when
you wanted to collapse two vectors for
the same word did you say you usually
take the average um different people
have done different things but the most
common practice is after you've uh you
know there's still a bit more i have to
cover about running word divec that we
didn't really get through today so i
still got a bit more work to do on
thursday but you know once you've run
your word to vec algorithm
and you you sort of your output is two
vectors for each word and kind of like
when it's center and when it's context
and
so typically people just average those
two vectors and say okay that's the
representation of the word croissant and
that's what appears in the sort of word
vectors file like the one i loaded
that makes sense thank you
oh thanks so my question is if a word
have two different meanings or multiple
different meanings can we still
represent it as a same
single vector
yes that's a very good question um and
actually there is some content on that
in thursday's lecture so i can say more
about that um but yeah the first
reaction is you kind of should be scared
because um something i've said nothing
about at all is you know
most words especially short common words
have lots of meaning so if you have a
word like star that can be astronomical
object or it can be you know a film star
a hollywood star or it can be something
like the gold stars that you've got in
elementary school
and
we're just taking all those
uses of the word star and collapsing
them together
into one word vector um and you might
think that's really crazy and bad um but
actually turns out to work rather well
um
maybe i won't go through all of that um
right now because there is actually
stuff on that on thursday's lecture
oh i see i think you can put ahead of
the slides for next time oh wait
i know this let's see
[Music]
is
do we
look at
how to implement or do we look at like
the stack of like something like alexa
or something provide speech to uh
context actions in this course was it
just primarily
uh
understanding so this is an unusual con
an unusual quarter
but for this quarter there's a very
clear answer which is
um
this quarter um there's also a speech
class being taught which is cs 224 s
um a speech class being taught by andrew
mars and you know this is a class that's
been more regularly offered sometimes
it's only been offered every third year
but it's being offered right now so if
what you want to do is learn about
speech recognition and learn about sort
of methods for building dialogue systems
you should do
cs224 yes
so you know for this class in general um
the vast bulk of this class is working
with text and doing various kinds of
text analysis and understanding so we do
tasks like some of the ones i mentioned
we do machine translation um we
do question answering um we look at how
to pass this structure of sentences and
things like that you know in other years
i sometimes say a little bit about
speech um but
since this quarter there's a whole
different class that's focused on speech
that seem a little bit silly
i guess you have the
the part of partnering with your
audience
[Music]
more on speech
i'm now getting a bad echo i'm not sure
if that's my fault or your fault but
anyway um
anyway answer yeah so the speech class
does a mix of stuff so i mean the sort
of pure speech problems classically have
been um doing speech recognition so
going from a speech signal to text and
doing
text-to-speech going from text to us
a speech signal and both of those are
problems which are now normally done
including
by the cell phone that sits in your
pocket
using neural networks and so it covers
both of those but then between that
the class covers quite a bit and in
particular it starts off with
looking at building dialogue system so
this is sort of something like alexa
google assistant siri as to
well assuming you have a speech
recognition a text-to-speech system
um then you do have text in and text out
what are the kind of ways that people go
about building um
um
dialogue systems like the ones that i
just mentioned
um i actually had a question so
i think there was some people in the
chat noticing that the uh like opposites
were really near to each other which was
kind of odd but i was also wondering um
what about like positive and negative uh
valence or like affect um is that
captured well in this type of model or
is it like not captured well like well
like with the opposites how those
weren't really yeah so the short answer
is for both of those and so this is a
good question a good observation and
the short answer is no both of those are
captured really really badly i mean
there's there's a definition
um
oh you know when i say really really
badly i mean
what i mean is if that's
what you want to focus on um you've got
problems i mean it's not that the
algorithm doesn't work so
precisely what you find
is that you know antonyms generally
occur in very similar topics because you
know whether it's um
saying you know john is really tall or
john is really short or that movie was
fantastic or that movie was terrible
right you get
antonyms occurring in the same context
so because of that their vectors are
very similar and similarly for sort of
affect and sentiment based words well
like um great and terrible example
their contexts are similar um they're
for um
that if you're just learning this kind
of predict words and context models um
that no that's not captured now that's
not the end of the story i mean you know
absolutely people wanted to use neural
networks for sentiment and other kinds
of sort of connotation effect and there
are very good ways of doing that but
somehow you have to do something more
than simply predicting words in context
because that's not sufficient to um
capture that dimension
um more on that later
adjectives too like very basic
adjectives like so and like not
because those would like appear in like
similar context right
what was your first example before not
uh like so this is so cool so that
that's actually a good question as well
so
yeah so there are these very common
words that are commonly referred to as
function words by linguists which you
know includes ones like um
so and not but other ones like and and
prepositions like you know two and on
um
you sort of might suspect that the word
vectors for those don't
work out very well because they occur in
all kinds of different contexts and
they're not very distinct from each
other in many cases and to a first
approximation i think that's true and
part of why i didn't use those as
examples in my slides yeah
but you know at the end of the day we do
build up vector representations of those
words too and you'll see in a few
lectures time when we start building
what we call language models that
actually they do do a great job in those
words as well i mean to explain what i'm
meaning there i mean
you know
another
feature of the word to vect model is
that actually ignore the position of
words right so it said i'm going to
predict every word around the center
word but you know i'm predicting it in
the same way i'm not predicting
differently the word before me or versus
the word after me or the word two away
in either direction right they're all
just predicted the same by that one um
probability function and so if that's
all you've got that sort of destroys
your ability to do a good job at um
capturing these sort of common more
grammatical words like so not an and
but we build slightly different models
that are more sensitive to the structure
of sentences and then we start doing a
good job on those too
okay thank you
i had a question about the
characterization of word to fact
um because i i
which was slightly different from how it
was presented in the microwave so are
these like two complementary reasons
yeah so
i i've still got more to say so i'm stay
tuned thursday um for more stuff on word
vectors um you know so
word to back
is kind of a framework for building word
vectors and that there are sort of
several variant precise algorithms
within the framework and
you know one of them is
how whether you're predicting the
context words or whether you're
predicting the center word
so the model i showed was predicting the
context words so it was the skip gram
model but then there's sort of a detail
of how in particular do you do the
optimization and what i presented was
the sort of easiest way to do it which
is
naive optimization
with the
equation the soft max equation for word
vectors um it turns out that that naive
optimization is sort of ex needlessly
expensive and people have come up with
um a faster ways of doing it in
particular um the commonest thing you
see is what's called skip gram with
negative sampling and the negative
sampling is then sort of a much more
efficient way to estimate things and
i'll mention that on thursday
right okay
thank you
who's asking for more information about
how word vectors are constructed uh
beyond the summary of random
initialization and then
gradient based uh
iterative upgrade optimization yeah um
so i sort of will do a bit more
connecting this together um in the
thursday lecture i guess this sort of
only so much one can fit in the first
class
um but the pic
the picture is essentially the picture i
showed the pieces of so
to learn word vectors
you start off by having a vector for
each
word type both for context and outside
and those vectors you initialize
randomly
so
that you just put small little numbers
that are randomly generated in each
vector component and that's just your
starting point and so from there on
you're using an iterative algorithm
where you're progressively updating
those word vectors so they do a better
job at predicting which words appear in
the context of other words and the way
that we're going to do that is by using
um the gradients that i was sort of
starting to show how to calculate and
then you know once you have a gradient
you can walk in the opposite direction
of the gradient and you're then walking
downhill i you're minimizing your loss
and we're going to sort of do lots of
that until our word vectors get as good
as possible so you know
um
it's really all math but in some sense
you know word vector learning is sort of
miraculous since you do literally just
start off with completely random word
vectors
and
run this algorithm of predicting words
for a long time
and out of nothing emerges these word
vectors that represent meaning well